- All right, we gotta talk about these
folding phones for a minute,
because it's changed a lot
since the last time we did.
So the first ever folding
phone from OnePlus
came out this week.
It's called the OnePlus Open.
Not a very good name,
but a very, very, very good,
first gen foldable.
I've been using it for
about three weeks now.
I got lots of good things to say about it,
but it's actually, I
feel like it's so good,
that it's actually resurfaced
the old question in my head
from a couple years ago, which is,
what's it gonna take for regular people
to actually start buying folding phones?
Because, yeah, I like this phone,
and I'm gonna go ahead and guess that
some other reviewers
will like this phone too,
and some enthusiasts will like this phone,
and this video may even
get a lot of views,
but none of that necessarily translates
into regular people just
like, strolling into a store,
or going online and choosing
to buy one of these.
So first things first,
the details of this phone.
So this is a super high-end
phone in every way,
and the design is
particularly well considered.
You can see it's basically the same size
as a normal phone on the outside.
This is a 6.3 inch, 20
by nine cover display,
just over 1080p.
It's LTPO down to 10 hertz,
and it's an absurdly bright
2800 nits max brightness
between these pretty thin bezels.
So this actually does take the crown now
for the brightest display I
have ever seen in a smartphone.
And I'm gonna go ahead
and give it the co-crown
for best foldable to use while closed,
alongside the Pixel Fold.
So I still think the Pixel Fold has,
it's more reachable, it has
better button placement,
since it's a bit shorter.
But there's no question this
feels like a flagship phone
on the outside, even if you
never even open the thing.
There's also a bunch of
design touches I really like,
the flat sides all the
way around, super clean.
The alert slider is also back,
so it's way up there at
the top of the phone,
which is kind of tough to reach,
but I love that it works
exactly as you'd expect.
Same as previous OnePlus
phones that had it.
And the power button also doubles
as the fingerprint reader,
which we've seen with lots
of these folds as well.
It's awesome.
And then around the back,
mixed bag, I would say.
I'm not the biggest fake leather
on the back of a phone person.
It gives me like, Samsung 2016 vibes,
but at least it does hide fingerprints.
This is the other color now.
It's a green.
It looks a little bit cleaner.
But really, the feature is
the gigantic camera bump.
And yeah, it's pretty crazy looking,
but, but, it also happens to be
exactly where my index finger rests
on the back of the phone.
So it's like a nice little shelf
that feels really natural when
using the phone while closed.
So I kind of really like it for that.
Also, the LED flash.
I guess it couldn't fit,
so they shoved it up in the
corner, for some reason.
But, then you open this thing up,
and it just, it becomes so
obvious why they waited so long
to do their first foldable.
It looks nothing like some of the other
first gen folding screens from years ago.
It's got this huge 7.8
inch corner to corner,
LTPO 3.0 display, that again,
goes up to 2800 nits,
and down to one hertz.
Even bezels all the way around,
got the hole punch in the top corner.
And honestly, one of the
least visible creases
you will see in a folding phone in 2023.
Now I think it's actually debatable
if we can technically call this
their first foldable phone,
because while OnePlus
hasn't made a foldable yet,
their sister company, OPPO, clearly has.
So I wouldn't be surprised
if this took a lot of tech from them.
Actually, there is another
just released OPPO phone
called the OPPO Find N3,
and it's the same as this,
but the point still stands.
And with this screen on,
you literally don't see the
crease at all, and screen off,
you still kind of have to look for it.
And then, yeah,
you hit the angle where the light reflects
off of the middle of the
phone, and then you can see it.
But this is one of those phones that
looks really good from almost every angle
you would actually use it.
And then it also has one of those hinges
that stays at whatever
angle that you hold it at.
So if you want a sort
of a 90 degree angle,
or a little bit more open
or closed, you can do that.
And then it has a nice satisfying
spring loaded clap shut.
It's also, it's impressively thin.
It's not the thinnest one I've
ever seen, but pretty good.
It's lighter than you would expect.
It's actually, if you put it on a scale,
it's basically the exact same
weight as an iPhone 14 Pro
when they're doing stainless steel.
So, just a regular phone weight.
So it's an impressive piece of hardware.
But then the software
for this one is OnePlus.
So it's OxygenOS 13.2,
and it's got all kinds of little
tweaks and little features
that power users are gonna love.
Because let's face it, this
is a phone for power users.
People who are gonna love the
continuity features
between the open screen
and the closed screen.
So once you're done using a big app,
you just close it like this,
and then swipe up to pick
up where you left off
on the outside screen, if you want to.
Just like the Pixel Fold,
it's gonna mirror your home
screen set up automatically
between the cover screen
and the inside screen.
So if you change something,
like move a folder or a
widget or an app on one,
and then switch to the other,
it will have also moved from there too.
Keeps them a little bit more organized.
I kind of wish I had the
option to change that,
since this is Android,
and I am a power user.
But nevertheless, that's the way it is.
But then there's also a ton
of multitasking features
on the inside screen, for having
multiple apps open at once.
So you can have, obviously,
one app open full screen,
and that looks good for a
surprising number of apps.
It'll stretch them if they're
not natively built for this.
But then you can have
two apps side by side,
and then you can pick a
third app to get in the mix.
Then they're all just
sort of next to each other
in this triple panel view,
and you can move things
between them really quickly.
Or if you pinch out with four fingers,
you can see all of the apps at once.
So between that and the dock,
with all of your apps and recent files,
it's just a very well considered hub for
sitting down and just getting stuff done.
Like I feel like when I sit
down and open this phone,
I'm about to be really
productive and get a lot done.
This phone, the OnePlus Open,
honestly, as a phone,
it nails all five of my
pillars of a great smartphone.
Great screen, great battery,
great build, great performance,
great camera, and I'm not
being generous with that stuff.
It like, actually nails all of that stuff.
Like you already heard
about the great screen,
and the fact that they
match each other so well
inside and outside, is
already pretty great.
There's also great performance.
Super high-end specs.
Snapdragon 8 gen 2, 16 gigs of fast RAM,
512 gigs of UFS 4.0 storage.
I mean the pair of 120 hertz LTPO displays
have a 240 hertz touch sample rate.
It's super responsive, and I mean,
the whole thing feels very future-proof.
And then you also heard
about the build quality,
which I'll revisit that in a second.
But then battery life
has also been excellent,
with this 4800 MilliAmp hour battery,
and 67 watt fast charging,
although it just skips wireless
charging, for some reason,
which is like the most OnePlus thing ever.
I think it adds like,
no cost and no weight and no thickness,
but yet they leave it out
when all the other
competitors have it anyway?
Alright, fine.
But then this huge
camera module on the back
kind of implies high end cameras,
but you can never really be
sure until you test them.
And sure enough, this
(indistinct) camera setup
is pretty decent.
It's got this new stacked
sensor for the primary sensor,
a 3x telephoto, and an ultra wide.
I found it's pretty good most of the time,
although it's not very
good at freezing motion.
Which is fine if you take
photos of still subjects,
but the second it's people or animals,
and those things start to move,
then it can be kind of hard
getting a shutter speed fast
enough to freeze that stuff.
You basically have to
switch to action mode,
which there's a button for.
And that works by
cranking the shutter speed
way up, as expected,
but then ISO starts to get a little high,
high enough that photos
are now a little noisier,
a little worse looking,
so it's just, that's unfortunate.
And by the way, this isn't
one of the five pillars,
but I also found that the
microphone on this phone
is actually quite good.
They're usually not this good.
I was pleasantly surprised.
But it all comes together
in a really nice phone
that I think a lot of
people including myself
are gonna really like using.
So the question is,
why do I think people aren't buying
folding phones that much,
if they're this good?
It turns out, a phone
can hit all five pillars
of a great smartphone,
and not be a great buy
for everyone, necessarily.
And so it really comes down
to three things, I think.
Number one is still price.
Number two is the durability question.
And then number three is
just the power user problem.
So on price, this phone is $1700 US.
That is a lot of money
to spend on a phone,
no matter how you chop it
up into monthly segments
or staggered payments.
It's just a lot, right?
It's literally twice as
much as an iPhone 15.
But guess what?
That's literally right in line
with its folding competitors,
like the other two folding
phones available in the US,
Pixel Fold, $1800.
Samsung Z Fold 5. $1800.
So this one's actually kind of a bargain.
That's the most obvious
thing holding these back,
'cause they're still so expensive.
But then number two,
durability is also questionable at best.
Now of course, they do all
the testing that they can,
and guess what?
They've got IPX4 water
resistance, which is nice.
And they have a durability rating
for a million folds of the
hinge, and that's great.
But then, what about these dead pixels
that have started appearing
at the bottom middle of my screen,
right around the hinge?
I had this one for three
weeks, and babied it,
and this is already
starting to show up on mine.
It doesn't mean it's
gonna be bad for everyone,
but that's not great,
and I suspect it's not gonna
happen on non-folding phones.
But the third and final
reason folding phones,
as great as they've been getting,
aren't necessarily translating
to mainstream success,
is that they're power user phones.
They're, folding and unfolding
is a power user feature.
And power user features,
as much as we love 'em,
don't sell a ton of phones.
We figured this out many times
when LG spent years and years
making some of the most
manually adjustable cameras
in the smartphone world,
and now they don't make
smartphones anymore.
And we still have Sony,
who can't stop making professional cameras
in a smartphone body,
but their sales are putting them
in danger of the same thing.
And Asus ZenFones are
absolutely incredible right now,
for enthusiasts like myself,
but they've already thrown a head fake.
Clearly they're not
doing super well either.
I'd honestly be willing to bet,
without even being able to
look into anyone's books,
that the folding phones
are not at the top of sales
in any of the lineups
of any of the companies
who are making these things.
Probably the most compelling
folding phone hardware
I've seen yet, is this HONOR phone.
This thing's called the HONOR Magic V2.
Bro, look at this thing!
This, it's super thin,
it has all the right things
in all the right places.
It's got a 3D printed
titanium hinge cover,
barely showing any crease when it's open.
Thin bezels, nice screens
all the way around.
Somehow it has a 5000
MilliAmp hour battery inside,
and high-end specs.
Like, playing with this phone
over almost anything else,
over even Samsung's,
has helped me appreciate
what folding phone hardware
can actually be.
But despite all that awesomeness,
it still has those kind
of obvious downsides
for a regular person,
to probably not pick it
over a regular phone.
The price, it's like 1400 bucks.
The durability?
Potentially compromised, we don't know.
And then even though
it is thin and awesome,
it's still just like,
the power user thing of wanting to carry
a slightly thicker phone around
and have that extra ability
is not something everyone sees as obvious
and something they actually want.
We are starting to
finally see some of those
flipping phones come at least
closer to the mainstream,
because they are lower in price.
The the Z Flip 5 is down to a
thousand bucks from Samsung.
And Motorola just launched
their most affordable flip yet,
the Razr 40, I think is
launching soon at 600 bucks.
So that seems to be getting
closer, but it's just,
we need a lot more of that stuff.
So, folding phones are simultaneously
very evolved from their
beginnings just a few years ago,
and yet still have a long way to go.
So I guess until we get there,
it's more fun for us nerds.
Thanks for watching!
Catch you in the next one.
Peace.
(chill beats and uplifting strings music)